well good morning everybody and welcome
to this develop
control meeting my name is Cathy Guthrie
and I'm the chairman today now first of
all remind you of some domestic
arrangements toilets are situated
outside the meeting room opposite the
stairs cold water is also available
outside the meeting room
if the far along should sound please
leave the meeting room by following the
fire exit signs and meet on the Ipswich
Town Football Club training pitch do not
re-enter the building until you are told
as is safe to do so please switch your
four mobile phones or turn them to
silent I would like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be live
broadcast on to the internet and will be
capable of repeated viewing the whole of
the meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and all training purposes the
council members of the public and press
may be called film photograph will
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
finally can members and officers please
ensure that you press the microphone for
speaking and turn off when you have
finished so the introductions are on the
top table here we have the into prayer
legal officer we have Phillip Isabella
head of planning chief planning officer
as myself of course Cathy Guthrie we
have Robert Carmichael our governance
officer Vincent Pierce who will be one
of the planning senior planning officers
to present a case or two and Mandy Smith
who's in charge of steering and
everything that goes wrong with the
Internet
we have other warden and other officers
there we have warden amber availability
here most importantly we have our
counselors who are elected councillors
and will debate and make a decision on
the application before you we do have
one person who's running late they may
attend the chamber but if they have not
been at the beginning of the debate they
will not be allowed to vote on that
particular application and then of
course there's your good cells in the
back they're made up of members of the
public applicants agents and if you have
requested your three minutes to speak we
have the technology and you are very
welcome to come and speak I think that
covers everything there so we move on to
the agenda if you would please apologies
for absence and substitutions Thank You
chair we have one apology this morning
from councillor Richardson and
councillor Mayer is substituting for him
anyone as we've said as well as Kasim
Matson is running late to receive any
declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members no
declaration of lobbying yes I think we
all had a letter I is this for the first
and second items first and third right
okay thank you declarations of personal
site visits confirmation of the minutes
of the meeting held on the 2nd of
October and there has yeah there has
been a slight amendment to one page of
it thank you Jeff there's just one
slight amendment for clarity purposes
which is in 58 point 2 12 of the minutes
and is to read as follows in stead of
the current wording so after considering
the concerns raised by members the
report from the officer the
representation is from the public
speakers and the debate from members the
chair decided to send the application to
the Planning referrals committee formed
of the MSD C development control a and B
committees for determination due to
significant concerns that have been
raised regarding the application just a
bit of so thank you for that and with
anything else involved I won't go
through it page by page unless there's
an amendment required so pages 1 2
ten can I sign those minutes please
thank you very much I'll do that during
the meeting thank you to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the councilors petition scheme none
received you and the schedule of
planning applications will be the order
in which they appear on the papers and
just as a little extra to help everybody
running through this I'm sure you've all
worked it out for yourselves but if from
those of you who have paper copies would
like to turn to page 39 you'll see we
now have an index of things and this is
helpful to members because everything is
going to be in there each time
unfortunately there wasn't a page
reference to it so if you wonder one run
through the page reference that I've put
down nothing for the first run appendix
one appendix 2 is on page 24 appendix 3
is on 41 to 42 appendix 5 flood and
water 43 fire and rescue 44 45 46
highways 48 public realm 49 and
enforcement 50 so if anybody wants to
refer the papers we've got them all down
there so three of them so well and just
one moment
well yes okay so that's very helpful
thank you actually page 24 it's the
planning history of it but we've
actually got the late papers of the the
the previous decision so that was sorry
am i misleading thing there so we've got
that in late papers okay so thank you
very much because if you would like to
help us with this one and start the
application thank you Thank You Jacob
morning members scuzzy ladies and
gentlemen but members of the public
first item this morning is a
retrospective planning application at AI
airfield and although the postal address
is Casselton way i it is actually in the
parish of Yaxley what I want to do
because this is a retrospective
application i it is the applicant is now
seeking planning permission for works
that have already been undertaken and
they have they are doing it in the
format of a full application I just need
to explain that a planning master
preventing breach has occurred insofar
as they have extended the property
without planning permission that in
itself is not illegal I do need to
emphasize that
also not before you this morning are a
number of other applications listed on
the screen that will be dealt with in
due course we're still considering those
since can I just hold you for one second
please we have got councillor Matheson I
wonder can we start again
do you mind it is just a short thing
your bag to take a seat counselor
Matheson well I just don't worry about
signing anything we know you're here
yeah and while you're walking up there
can you think have you got any
declarations of interest have you had
any personal site visits yes thank you
and have you heard any lobbying we've
had a letter did you have a letter for
the first - thank you for that counselor
sorry to rush you on but we literally
have literally just started so thank you
very much Vince if you'd like to just
start again when he plants the Matheson
estate in this seat
[Music]
come on you kill flemeth's
are you comfortable we're just going to
get your glass of office in case that's
helpful as well
the money count for medicine what we're
looking at first is a retrospective full
application for cancer seeking planning
permission for works that have already
been undertaken and whilst the postal
address of this site is Castleton away.i
it is actually within the parish of
Yaxley you'll note from the committee
report that there is a planning
permission already for the construction
of a chicken processing plant what we're
looking at today are a number of
extensions to that building and we're
seeking or the applicants are seeking to
regularize those extensions because they
weren't included in the earlier planning
permission I need to re-emphasize that
the undertaking of development without
planning permission is not illegal so
whilst this is a retrospective planning
application the applicants have not
committed an offense behind the scenes
we have another five applications that
are currently under consideration for
works that have been undertaken that
weren't part of the original planning
permission but they are not matters that
I am bringing you this morning they will
be dealt with outside of this meeting at
a future date as you can see the
boundary between I and Yaxley is just
the right of the application site Yaxley
and I sit in the northern half of the
district
in my view the issues that members are
going to have to grapple with this
morning in terms of the planning issues
will the building as now extended result
in a material increase in the number of
chickens being processed and the answer
to that is no will the extensions result
in a material and detrimental increase
in traffic and we will look at that that
issue because I know that's a concern of
many local people will they result in a
material loss of parking spaces there
has been concern expressed that the
number of parking spaces which should
have been provided are now being under
provided and we can deal with that and
the short answer is no there is a slight
increase will the extensions result in
visual harm and were the extensions
result in new forms of residential
amenity harm by people living nearby and
the other question is doesn't do the
extensions raise any new issues that
weren't previously considered so on the
left of the screen you will just see in
move a number of extensions on the outer
edges of the building I've got a much
clearer slide so I'll come to that in a
moment I've identified in red the actual
processing plant access to it is via a
connection to the a1 40 which runs
north-south just to the left of the
processing plant and there's a service
access to the right showing them right
on that screen aerial photograph you'll
notice that this is at the southern end
of I airfield and there is already a lot
of development at the northern end we
may come on to more recent developments
at the northern end as we go through
this presentation
in the emerging local plan the flashing
blue circle and their little red
processing plant in the middle of it is
clearly within an employment area hence
the reason that the processing plant was
approved in the first place so we're now
looking at a question of land use on
this occasion we're so perfectly
satisfied that the extensions are
acceptable in principle within an
employment area I put a neighborhood
plan on the screen because we have had
representations from I Town Council but
as I said at the start of the
presentation the site is actually within
Yaxley suffice to say there is nothing
proposed here that is contrary to the
neighborhood plan in I the only adopted
plan that we have in respect to the
airfield and this is adopted guidance
take suspect in 2030 is a planning
position statement and you'll notice
from the diagram on the right that the
chicken process plant is within an area
that was always envisaged to be
employment uses we've had a number of
other documents that have come later but
they do not have any formal status but
I've put them on the screen for the sake
of being comprehensive very few
constraints in the immediate locality we
have a footpath some distance away to
the northwest and we have a little
cluster of listed buildings within
Yaxley but on the other side of the a1
40 so remote from the chicken processing
plant so let's look at the extensions
one by one first extension it's merely
an extension to the background
production
area a modest extension of just 132
square meters to level extensions either
side of the stairwell we have a new
workshop area shown in the pink color
that's so that Krenz we can actually
have on-site engineering capability
rather than having to call people in and
in terms of operational efficiency that
makes perfect sense to have the team
on-site because if any part of the
machinery is down even for a short while
it does have an impact on their ability
to process the chickens
so from an employment point of view that
is engineering jobs that we will endorse
but it's also good from operational
perspective we also have additional
production office areas very thin strip
we have a new entrance feature also part
of the reason for the extensions is
because friends we have been fortunate
in that one of their latest customers as
asked for fresh chicken that has been
marinated and what they have done is
provide a new marinating area within the
plant so that fresh chicken can be
flavored ready to be sent to two
customers so that in itself does not
result in an increase in capacity or
throughput of chickens but it does
enable cremes WIC to widen their offer
to potential customers
there is nothing within the extensions
that has increased the throughput of
chickens these are all added facilities
to make the factory more effective
and the operational aspects easier so
here we have a view looking towards the
a 140 which is at the back of the slide
I'll just run through the extensions you
can see extension one very modest
extension two you can't really notice
either side of the staircase that's
extension two three four five
I'll show you separately that Central's
building six is a tiny corner extension
and seven is a thin strip on the edge of
the building but in terms of the
entrance it isn't that color but the
area shaded blue is a new entrance
feature you'll notice the car park in
the foreground so extension one merely
allows improved cleaning facilities and
you can imagine in a chicken processing
plant cleaning and hygiene is of the
utmost importance
very modest extensions around the
stairwells again to provide additional
hygiene facilities and additional
staircase maneuvering room extension
three is the marinade that's the
maintenance workshop and you'll notice
there are actual workshops in there
that's where parts will be replaced
repaired and and other bits and pieces
go on in terms of routine maintenance
the plant already has a marinade room
but because of the requirements of the
new customer that has been extended
slightly to give them more room the
actual entrance extension doesn't fill
the whole space the actual glass
frontage is set back behind or under a
canopy so the extension isn't as big as
the plan suggests and that provides rain
cover at the entrance a driver's
restroom you should imagine that drivers
of the chicken lorries need somewhere to
rest up between trips that is now
provided and there's a plant room
extension again a modest strip on the
edge of the building in terms of car
parking what we have is I think it's an
increase of 7 overall but I've marked on
the screen the actual numbers so you can
see between the large car park excuse me
a moment I just the large surface car
park remains and what we have are a
number of extended spaces at the
entrance to the site so I can confirm
categorically that there is no increases
that's no decrease in the number of
parking spaces whilst some of the
existing parking spaces have been taken
up with extensions the applicants have
been very careful to reap revise and
extend
parking spaces across the site so I
think some local people may have been
concerned when they saw parts of the
extensions sitting on the carpark but we
have ensured that the number of spaces
has increased
so there you have the previously
approved parking and you'll notice that
there wasn't the extra spaces to the
right of that near the entrance we seem
to have lost all functionality for a
second here we go so that's no the extra
parking I'll just flag so you can see in
terms of video we have a very short
section of video so that you can just
see the plant in the context of the a
140 hopefully you see the turbines you
see bits of industry in the background
and then you have the processing plant
itself
most of those extensions you wouldn't
even recognize from that vantage point
and that is the public vantage point
from the a 140 there isn't a path there
you would be driving in terms of a
catchment for the processing plant I do
need to describe how Krenz we operate
their their business what they have it's
a series of they only accept chickens
from farms that they own they only
accept chickens from within a 40 mile
radius and the advantage with this
location compared to their existing
location in Weybridge is that it sits
right on top of a strategic highway
network so lorries can come and go by
the a14 and the a 140 whereas previously
lorries were trundling through the
countryside to get to the plant in
Weybridge and that plant I understand
actually closed at the weekend so the
way breed operation is no longer
operational
the good news is that because the
extensions have not resulted in any
increase in capacity to process chickens
the number of lorry movements will not
increase to and from this site as a
result of the extensions that said of
course it is a an industrial area we are
as a council encouraging industrial
growth and you would expect that to be
accompanied by an increase in traffic
movements particularly from delivery
vehicles but in the case of the krenz
wick chicken processing plant
we don't expect there to be an increase
in traffic in terms of residential
amenity the nearest houses are on the
west side of the i-140 as hopefully I
could demonstrate from the video you
wouldn't notice the extensions from the
a 140 let alone the houses on the west
side of the a 114 the Exley so in terms
of the extensions you see on the screen
we are satisfied that there is no
adverse residential amenity impact and
on this screen I just highlight the
distances to nearest residential
properties so we've got 319 meters to
the closest and then to the bottom end
of Yaxley
it's 600 and I think there's this 53
meters remember we're talking about
relatively narrow extensions on a
previously approved factory building
to show you the complexity the building
that is simply a diagram of the
steelwork within the building there is
the frame under construction and that
contract went to a local steel
fabricator on the screen what you have
there's a series of slides that show as
built at the top compared to as approved
and I think you would probably be
hard-pressed to spot a difference other
than the obvious one in terms of the
relocation of the entrance feature and
additional glazing terms of side views
again very difficult to spot much of a
difference and you'll be comforted
hopefully by the fact that when we
looked at each of the extensions in turn
they weren't particularly big compared
to the overall mass of the approved
building what I've done here is I've
simply superimposed the as approved
which is the bottom image on top of the
as-built and we should just see that
there is a difference in profile at the
highest point at the ridge point that's
1.2 meters in my view that isn't
significant you wouldn't spot that from
the distances that we have in terms of
public viewing points and it is part of
the extension works it is part of the
additional windows to the elevations
I think for the better the pallet of
materials has been extended to break up
the monotony I would have suggested all
the the mass of the building so now we
have a combination of merlin grey goose
wing grey the original bright yellow
saffron yellow has been replaced by
Adalia yellow which is slightly softer
and and warmer
we have white elements and colors of
natural concrete and I think that
contrasts now help to disguise the mass
of the building much better than the
originally approved materials as part of
the construction work I think it is
worth recognizing that the xylem
waterworks have already been extended by
nearly a two million pound nearly 2
million pound extension now they need to
provide additional water to this
facility but also to provide water to I
in terms of any extensions that may
occur in I in terms of residential
development that capacity has now been
increased as a result of this
development friends whit themselves have
invested seventy five million pounds in
in the new chicken processing plant
you're all aware very aware of the
nature of employment in Suffolk grass
having only worked for the council for
18 months I needed to refresh my memory
and it is quite clear that agricultural
activity is unusually high in Suffolk in
terms of the importance to the local
economy as you can see it up strips that
of not just the east of England but also
England and there is no doubt that this
world-beating
processing plant the newest in Europe
the most efficient will assist
agriculture in Suffolk what I've done on
this slide is simply include some shots
of the progress power plant the gas
plant that's to be relocated at the
northern end of the airfield just to
give you an idea of scale of development
with on the air within the airfield and
I think it's fair to say that this
particular development dwarfs the cremes
wick Factory
so in a nutshell
there's officers we are satisfied that
the extensions will not cause an
increase in traffic it will not result
in a material increasing capacity at the
plant it will not harm residential
amenity it doesn't result in a loss of
car parking but actually results in a
very small increase all in all we are
satisfied that had this proposal being
submitted originally we would have
recommended approval thank you Jim
thank you I think thought it was just
going to add a little something there
for hey thank thank you yes Germany yes
you'll see from the report that there's
mention of the outstanding application
relating to the combined heat and power
system that's detailed on page 34 and 35
of your report and reference to the
Renewable Energy proposal associated
with this building that's still the
subject of ongoing discussion so from
our perspective as officers that's a
conversation outside this room that is
happening in the application is under
consideration from our point of view
we're working with the company to make
sure we've got a scheme that is
comfortable to our sustainability
officers working or working with us to
achieve that that's still live and in
fairness undecided so we have to be
cautious in what we as officers say
that's in hand I would just point out
and clarify one thing within the report
noting as as Vince has done for you the
height changes to the building and a
paragraph 4.1 the report did say there
was no increase in the previously
approved field a building height that is
actually incorrect so the the drawings
that you have as shown on the slides do
indicate the changes of those and
obviously with a wider span of building
and that's that's almost inevitable to
arrive at that point but if you've got
any questions around that
chairman happy to to pick that point out
further on on either matter thank you
thank you for that so members do you
have any questions for Vince it was a
very comprehensive report there does
anybody have any questions
councillor wall boys thank you just a
couple really okay I'd just like to say
thank you that was a really clear
presentation it's another outstanding
element I think which is a lighting
scheme I just don't know whether like
the renewable energy the Bienstock
discussions about that and the second
question was with regards to the parking
is there any sort of facility there for
charging Bay's or bicycles
[Music]
Thank You counselor war boys the
lighting scheme is is a matter for
dischargeable condition so that will be
dealt with separately outside of this
particular proposal in terms of the
parking I there is adequate cycle
parking included within the scheme but
you make a very interesting point about
the electric vehicle charging I don't
believe that the scheme includes any
electric vehicle charging points and I
think it would be reasonable as this is
a full application where members minded
to require some Eevee charging points
that we could add that by way of
condition thank Joan yes so the original
permission that's in your table papers
the late papers you'll see the decision
notice there and just so we're clear
there was a lighting like lighting
design scheme required as condition 22
and indeed condition 20 related to cycle
parking I think in fairness what what
what you have in condition 20 on on page
10 of those table papers is our usual
and traditional cycle parking condition
which predates the invention of the
electric bicycle it's not so that
planners are at the forefront of
Transport change but we could happily
include within that provision for
charging for electric bicycles as as a
as I matter to be picked up as you'll
see on page 37 we are proposing the
reproduction of these conditions and I'm
happy to suggest that we include
provision for charging electric bicycles
within that proposal as a way of dealing
with it as appelles lighting
I don't believe and forgive me I don't
believe I've seen a detailed submission
on that at this point in time as the
building is not yet complete I suspect
that's a little little early but from my
point of view we are expecting that and
we will be looking at that this is a
matter obviously we're already into the
question of an enforcement investigation
regarding the retrospective nature of
the development so I'm fairly
comfortable from my point of view that
Krenz we can understand their
responsibilities under these conditions
and will look to deal with both lighting
and the renewable energy condition in a
reasonable manner with us but have to
pursue that if let's just ask in terms
of electric charging I think council of
war boys was also asking for vehicles as
well it's not something that we've done
previously I think in practical terms
there's a there's a sense to that and
that's worth worthwhile taking away to
include that as a scheme within the
provision of parking and turning on this
which is condition 19 as listed so I
think we can do both bicycles and cars
sorry took a steer and went in one
direction apologies I must admit I
thought that was the glass half full or
half empty because I was thinking the
same as you as cars and it was a very
interesting thought about electric bikes
actually so so we've got a double whammy
on that one yeah thank you um yes cancel
birth Thank You German and I'd like to
ask Vincent please he mentioned in his
you mentioned in your presentation that
the progress power
gus-gus pilot pro power station which
does have an extent development consent
order on the airfield he your
presentation suggested that it was going
to go ahead in a sense that you didn't
say it was a proposal and not a
comparison not a completed one have you
any information that I don't have which
suggests that it is indeed going to go
ahead thank you
I do have another question after this
yeah can you stick to this planning
application as well thank you um yeah no
no we don't have any information it will
go go ahead it has been the subject of a
nationally a significant infrastructure
project application and has a
development consent order I think it's
fair to say the question of the funding
to make that happen is not yet been
settled so at the moment it remains a
scheme but it has a consent and so from
our point of view as part of the
planning context on the airfield it's a
relevant decision albeit clearly and if
you go back to your site layout plan
Vince that will be really helpful it
will appear in the further distance of
the airfield together with the existing
power station on on the airfield so if I
wait while my glamorous assistant finds
the relevant plan the point is there is
a consent from our perspective and the
Secretary of State has given
consideration to the landscape context
of our airfield and as one small feature
of that there is there is a development
consent order for a gas-fired power
station
further to the north if you go back to
that previous slide that you had Vince
that will do our purpose if you go back
one forward one should we say so where
you were next one so in this the
northernmost yellow blob but like that
that makes --nt in the northernmost part
of that has been the subject of this n
cept n sip consent order and obviously
that will appear in the distance
compared to whether site we're dealing
with from the custom way area but as
part of the visual quality of airfield
and inconsistency with the original
landscape advice has quoted in the
report there is already a range of
industrial and the utilitarian
structures on the airfield which all
provide context to which this is
completely consistent I hope that kind
of deals with it councillor burn in a
way that provides the uncertainty you
were hoping for your next question
please councillor burn Vickie it's the
the lighting scheme which is
subject of discharge of condition but
I'd like to know whether if that some of
that lighting scheme has already been
implemented can you have a retrospective
discharge of conditions or would the
actual completion of a lighting scheme
or partial completion of a lighting
scheme that has not yet been discharged
require a further retrospective planning
application specifically I'm talking
about the lighting scheme that
illuminates the car parking area so if
perhaps if I pick that issue up on page
10 of the light papers the lighting
scheme a design a lighting design design
scheme including details of lights
proposed on buildings for security
purposes and for lighting the external
circulation areas is the requirement
that was set out that is required prior
to occupation and the building isn't
occupied is still under construction so
in first principles we're not yet at the
point where that is essential so we're
not into a retrospective element there
secondly it is perfectly possible to
seek approval for that in a
retrospective way we would deal with
that as a common sense submission where
the enforcement team to investigate that
the usual approach would be to politely
and firmly invite the necessary
application to discharge the condition
at the earliest opportunity and then to
engage in dialogue about that so from
our point of view much as you can have a
retrospective application for planning
permission you can also apply in
retrospect to discharge a condition it
would seem unhelpful not to be able to
do that and from our point of view we
are aware that the humphreys development
of north is visually noticeable at night
shall we say and this site will be no
less so inevitably with a building
layout such as this it is unavoidable
that you will see
some some lighting impacts in the night
sky but minimizing those and shielding
lights such that there is as little
spill as possible is part of our
objective and and so from our point of
view we are focused on making sure that
we achieve that result Council any
further questions no well we don't have
anyone from the first council or an
objector or a supporter but we have
David Park the applicant or the agent if
you'd like to come forward please
ok bye good morning members thank you
for seeing us this morning my name is
David Park I'm a director of crams ouack
the reason for the planning applications
that were put forward today coming
retrospectively is that our building has
evolved as we have been as we've been
executing the build that's largely due
to the fact that when we started
building we had a forecasted sales
profile for our throughput and that
crystallized into being a actual sales
profile as a result of gaining a new
customer for the majority of the
throughput of the factory so it's been
fairly widely publicized that we've
agreed a supply agreement with
Morrison's supermarket group to supply
in excess of 80 percent of their fresh
poultry requirement fresh chicken
requirement and that has led to the fact
that they require most of their
throughput most of their product to be
in a cut of performance in a retail pack
whereas when we first put the
application in we thought that we were
probably going to process about 50% of
the product us as whole bird product and
that's meant that we've had to put a lot
more equipment within the footprint of
the building and we're having to further
process add value to
most of the capacity of the plant so
we're not actually producing any more
product but we will be we will be adding
value and further processing that
throughput in case of that that's the
main reason for having to put on
extensions to the building a couple of
other ones that are worthy of note are
the fact that when we when we designed
things like the intake bays we were
using European vehicle measurements and
we we have to amend those for UK
vehicles so that that pretty much covers
the reasons now just to just on the
questions that were brought up so as
electric charging is concerned we do
have provision for electric charging for
cars and for bikes within the car park
and as far as the external lighting is
concerned that planning condition is
signed off already okay so I'm available
for questions as is Ian Trembley my
architect if you have any questions for
us not sure do we do that now or do we
do that
sorry I was distracted what do you want
to know because I can't quite hear you
guys sorry as far as questions are
concerned yes internally my architect is
available as well um well I we will go
to questions to you yes I'm sure all of
us received the letter from your good
self and we welcome the investment in
mid Suffolk District Council area I mean
it's it's hugely important however and
your letter at the bottom says telling
us all you know everything you told us
in the letter which was why you know
what you are and what you do and
everything this is meanwhile I hope that
my letter has helped clarify the
position as to one with an enforcement
situation or or a retrospective
application
you've told us the reason as to why you
need it but you haven't told us the
reason as to why you did it
without planning permission I suppose
with a project of this size it's
difficult to get the design right
immediately we put we've probably been
planning the the site for three years
and even now there are things that we
would have done differently with the
benefit of hindsight now as your you can
imagine as we're building something of
that scale having never built one before
and and there having been no new primary
processing plants built in the last 30
years in the UK things are going things
are going to come out of the woodwork
that you know we should have designed in
the first place okay if we were
designing it now if we're rebuilding it
obviously we wouldn't have to we
wouldn't have to need the benefit of
hindsight can I cut you off there I
appreciate that
I mean I've built a house and I know I
wished I'd done things differently but
why didn't you apply for planning
permission you'd be applied for a huge
planning permission we want it we'd love
it but why didn't you go on all these
other things that's all I want to know
the answer to time I suppose time is our
biggest is our biggest it was our
biggest problem so Morrison's need the
product now and we're already we're
already being put under pressure by the
customer to deliver product without
going into too much detail they there
was a move from the biggest supermarket
group in the UK moved supply into
Morrison's existing supplier and they
gave notice to Morrison's that they
weren't going to supply anymore
okay so Morris is wounded we're in a
situation where they were going to be
they were going to be short short of
product or even you know no product on
the shelves so they needed us to fill
that gap okay so therefore we have to we
have to build our factory and get it
ready for final quarter of this year in
order to make sure that they got chicken
on the shelves now have we not done that
had we're not being able to give
assurances that we would be able to do
that then they wouldn't
they wouldn't have given us the contract
I hear what you're saying on that and
and it's very interesting that you've
got such an excellent contract which we
commend you but planning is planning and
that's what we're here today for thank
you I mean yes counselor Humphries
I'm sure thank you yeah I congratulate
you on your contract makes fantastic
it's great for with SIPP it's great for
employment and everything else what
question is this though in and I've got
a small business not on the scale of
yours but I do deal with tenders deal
with contracts I deal with changing
those contracts the evolution of them on
a daily basis but the thing I do
actually when is a change to the
contract or change to the customer
requirement first thing I start doing is
communicating and communicate with
suppliers communicate with venues
why didn't you communicate with the
planet I mean to say it's hindsight
would do it differently we and full of
apologies you that it's fantastic but
the point is this why didn't you
communicate again in hindsight we
probably should have communicated more
so and I apologize for that and that's
probably a oversight on ultimately my
behalf and and certainly my team and
it's something that I will take back to
them council of gold thank you
thank you but just a point about the
vehicles you you you refer to a
different size of vehicle are those
vehicles larger than than the ones you
were planning for hence the need for the
extensions not larger that's exactly the
same size as the vehicles that that we
use currently the the the mistake was
made because we started with a template
that was provided by the equipment
suppliers so the factory is
the equipment in the factory is it it's
a turnkey facility within the building
okay provided by a company called
Morrell and they are Icelandic owned but
they operate in across the world their
template was designed on a European
building if you if you wanted to go back
to the plan of the building the the lair
each area where the delivery vehicles
disembark there are four antechambers
okay and each one of those antechambers
has to hold a vehicle and we have an
interlocking door system and that's
around the making sure that we control
odor and making sure that we control
welfare okay and because we were working
on a European sized vehicle we were only
a few centimetres but when you've turned
that by four okay it becomes a it
becomes significant in order to get the
health and safety clearance around the
antechambers we had to make the fourth
antechamber slightly longer so no
exactly the same vehicles we've we've
heard that there is a need to change as
your plans have evolved over the last
few years there's also from ask
perspective and things have changed as
well since you had planning permission
we've declared a climate change
emergency you're asking for our
flexibility our commitment and can we
expect your commitment to the renewable
energy provisions to sustainability of
the site going forward I mean I don't
know if you know much about Kranz but we
are and our stated aim is to become the
most sustainable meat business in the
world okay we've got a huge project
ongoing project
of change that's going through the
business at the moment where we are
questioning every part of our
environmental credentials now as far as
the eye sight is concerned we are moving
we are moving our business from a hugely
unsustainable site in way bred over to I
the changes and the sustainability
features of the new site are you know
far far better than the way bred
business now one thing that I would draw
you to is the CHP system that we're
putting in this is a tried and tested
technology that we've got some of our
other factories so we're putting
combined heat and power system in which
will provide all of the electricity and
all of the heating on all of the hot
water for the plants far far more
efficient and will be far more efficient
and far more sustainable than any other
poultry facility in the UK that's so
definitely people quite happy to show
you around the factory and show you our
commitment to that as well as bring you
up to speed with our second nature
project which I which I talked about and
again so yes I'm quite comfortable with
that Thank You councillor Matheson
thank you yes I i I've actually been
looked lobbied I think three times
actually this year by people concerned
about additional new poultry sheds
around the district can you tell us the
what's the capacity of this plant
compared to the old factory in NI which
which I declare an interest I worked
there thirty years ago right okay so the
existing plant at Weybridge has a
capacity of about 550 thousand units per
week okay
however we are actually producing around
800
thousand units or 800,000 birds a week
and we're selling some birds live to
other processes no we are producing
800,000 now okay sorry sorry no no we
have explained sorry we're totally
vertically integrated okay so we we
produce we farm our own birds okay and
and we process them
we have farming capacity and capability
at the moment for 800,000 but we're only
a slaughtering and processing 550,000 at
our website the new eyesight will be
capable of processing somewhere between
1 and 1.2 million Birds per week okay so
we will have a requirement for another
another two to four hundred thousand
birds per week now that requirement is
already is already factored into our
plans and we already have enough
agriculture within our existing within
our existing estate and committed by by
other farmers okay and the the 400,000
that we're not producing at the moment
is largely going to come from a farming
group who are currently providing for
another processor so and we we put a
presentation to the planners explaining
where our agriculture is coming from and
what new agriculture we require and
actually we don't though a lot of those
planning applications are nothing to do
with us when I just stopped if you date
there at the moment because it's not
really meant to be a debate it's what
we're looking at today is what the
planning application is and that today's
information it's not an increase on the
production of birds is very interesting
because I'm sure that you can come and
tell
about Lassiter lay quite out of a
showing capacity use according to the
planet if I'm correct is as is is that
correct yes the plant has approved and
not built was built and is set up to
deal with the amount of Birds 1.2
million that mr. Pope mentioned there is
no increase but the important point if I
major I think Arthur Matheson is
commenting on a general perception or a
general fear across North mid Suffolk
that there could be an increase in
transportation related to chicken
processing plants because we are the
capital of the chicken production world
in the UK mr. Park is saying this
application has nothing to do with other
plants there may be other farmers who
want to increase their capacity but they
will not be going to Krenz wicks plant
in i those farmers have arrangements
with other processing plants and Krenz
which can't be held accountable for what
other farmers may be doing in Norfolk
Suffolk and the area I think is where
that answer goes I think that's very
helpful from everybody but no more
debate on the point I think we've
cleared it thank you if I could just
make a point on our vehicle movements
though vehicle movements coming in and
the vehicles the the new system that we
are using to transport birds it allows
us to get 35% more weight Birds on a
vehicle which makes us far more
efficient than we currently are and more
efficient than any other sites in the UK
not only that the location of the new
site to Vince's point the fact that
we're on there 140 a 14-1 for three
intersections means that we're not we
are not traveling our Birds entering the
debate and this should just be questions
and quick
and we've got we've got enough on that
we couldn't against ourselves you can
most helpful with the information right
thank you have we got any further
questions as a quick question and answer
no thank you very much indeed I'm sure
we will be seeing you again on other
applications thank you very much but we
have the ward member now councillor burn
thank you very much Thank You chairman
um I'm not going to take exception to
anything or very few things that have
been said today by the case officer or
the presenting officer or the applicant
I think that the process has been
followed very rigorously and very
properly I'm satisfied with that most of
the impacts that Vince highlighted for
us have been satisfactorily answered the
only thing I would like to bring to the
committee's attention is perhaps the
visual amenity in how I've got a
positive and a negative on the visual
amenity side the positive first the
changes that have been made to the
southern elevation which is the one that
you see from Casselton way custom way
being the road that runs from the a 140
at the south of the airfield through to
I from Catherine where you see the
southern elevation and the actual
alterations that have been made to this
elevation create jutting out pieces if I
can put it that way but that actually
break up the visual line instead of the
whole face of the building being
completely
flat for its entire enormous length it
is actually punctuated by differences in
depth which I think and that coupled
with the variation in color and the
added palette the added colors of gray
white etc to the palate who does
actually improve the visual impact of it
there's no getting away from the fact
there is a very large building there but
it is visually more easy on the eye
because of the actual alterations that
have been made and the one that I would
take to suggest this is a negative has
negative impact and that is the the
canopy or the entrance foyer at the
front of the building which is
significantly longer than the original
one and and seems to be even longer
because I think the the Western
extremity of the main building has been
moved slightly eastwards so it gives the
impression that that whole canopy with
its office space within at least half of
it has has has been extended quite
considerably now added to that fact
added to that is the fact that it is
this bright chrome yellow which is not a
no problem with chrome yellows of color
but it does make that particular part of
the building stand out very considerably
oh it's okay it is a commercial building
or one does need to draw attention to it
but the view that you saw of that canopy
there is a fully Western that's a fully
Western view and
effect is that the cars that move up in
their mail room for tea
and there aren't many pedestrians at
that point anyway so we're talking about
vehicle traffic the that view is only in
sight for a very short period of time
and more more of a view is the oblique
view from the north and from the south
where this particular canopy is very
much more intrusive than it is there and
in that respect and probably in that
respect only I would say that the visual
amenity of this building is it doesn't
get up the plus point from me on that
score forth on that score alone no apart
from that German I don't think I've got
any comment to make thank you very much
councillor and does anyone have any
questions for the ward member no thank
you very much thank you David then in
that case we'll go into debate thank you
you'd like to start us off castle
Humphreys go for a third way to be
polite but sermons nobody's jumping off
I'll start this off as explained to mr.
part all the disappointing that this is
composed of retrospective permission or
yep split permissions I have to go back
to the first slide really that the
officer showed and it was about the
effects on the immunity and you know I
can't see that there's any adverse or
additional adverse effects that this
extension effectively or extensions
brings to this plant pretty much the
same most of it you can't see and it's
all being done for the right reasons
isn't it we need appoinment you've got
any contract you have to you have to
amend your plan you have to do that
otherwise you have lost his contract
which have been bad for you or bad for
us as a County so I understand the
reasons you did it and I understand the
pace of business however as I said
before it would have helped if you'd
have actually communicated it at an
earlier stage you might have got a
little bit more buy-in a bit more
systems and I think that's perhaps the
thing for the future because it's true
isn't it if everybody went around
getting retrospective planning
permissions it basically made this
completely pointless and actually we'd
have chaos within the community so I
think the same applies to you as it is
to a householder to developer I'm stick
with the plan and communicate when it
changes as early as you can
having said all of that these changes in
my mind do not cause any change to the
amenity and they benefit the company
they benefit the district they benefit
our employees and overall I think it's a
fairly good plan actually for such a
large industrial sites on the right
place and therefore I'm going to jump
straight in I would like to propose
approval the recommendation and the
conditions set and did you want the
conditions with the electric the added
the little electric bicycles mode sure I
think that's already in mr. parks
already explained that you've already
got thank you thank you just for clarity
I mean I understand that's cranes
extraction of travel from our point of
view any confidence that these that
these are embodied in the decision we'd
expect to include them so I and
apologies for lack of clarity I had
intended that officers were amending
their recommendation to embrace those as
sensible were sensible points anyway Jim
earlier part of a conversation you happy
with cancer no chest right yes I accept
that this one right who else would like
to speak Catholic all thank you
not to take any of the committee's time
just to second what councilor Humphries
has said and endorse absolutely what
he's had to say about the shame that
this is being dealt with in a way that
it has I see nothing that would have led
the applicant to believe that this would
be a difficult process we are all wholly
supportive of the building itself is not
a thing of beauty never will be but the
beauty lies in the economic
fit to the area so I'd like to a second
live proposal thank you for that
counselor
you might think I was rude by having my
mobile phone on but I actually am rather
sad I go around the country taking
pictures of developments and there is a
fantastic one at Milton Keynes and
they've done a very clever design on the
colors that they've actually done dark
blue at the bottom and then they bring
lines of blue coming up to the top
putting white at the top now they've
tried to do that on the a14 near wool
pit and they've put green on the bottom
so didn't quite work but this is
something that blends into the big skies
we've got in Suffolk so maybe in the
future the yellow banana that they've
got there might be blended down when
they refresh just a thought but we've
got a proposer and a seconder anyone
else wishing to speak without laboring
the point I think we've all done jolly
well councillor Matheson yes just just
to say that I think that I the most
notable point about all this is that the
mysteries fellows as they exercise the
little discretion in bringing its a
committee because as it was less than
10% additional floor area anyway it
might almost have been gone through as
non-material etc etc so I think it was
right to bring it here and it was right
to to explain to the applicant that we
do take a dim view of large numbers of
retrospective applications which seem to
be rather a lot of lined up on this site
thank you for that in that case I have a
proposal in the second deck and all of
us vote those in favor please please
vote we are unanimous thank you very
much indeed and can we move
on to the next one please
this comes as no surprise that Vince
will be presenting this case as well
please page 59
Thank You chair another application at
the chicken processing plant hexley I
will skip through a number of these
because you will have seen the slides
previously what we're looking at is a
relocation of the aeration tank as I've
outlined in royal blue and the building
that goes with it has been enlarged what
we're not looking at are any of the
additional tanks that you can see on
site that we included within the red
area they are subject of another
application I identified on the previous
application that we're currently looking
at so we are purely restricting
ourselves to the area in rural blue
you'll notice from the plan on the right
previously we approved an aeration tank
and an associated building it has been
built in a slightly different position
the associated building is slightly
larger in terms of the footprint there
is an aerial stairway to the top of the
aeration tank on the drawing on the
screen that is shown on the right-hand
side of the circle see if we can
we're running out of this here we go
there it's the
staircase mine in this shot the blue
circle is the tank that we're looking at
the aeration tank the yellow circle and
the red circle are not matters before
you this morning they're subject of
other applications the aeration tank is
broadly the same size as previously
proposed it has now moved closer to the
processing plant which in many ways is a
good thing because you read it against
the backdrop of the existing plant the
actual processing building is much as
previously approved slightly larger
footprint but the the access to the top
of the aeration tank rather than being a
long raking ramp is now a series of dr.
Lake it's reduced the visual impact of
that structure simply by incorporating
these dog licks and that is the only
matter that you're being asked to look
at this morning
well perfectly satisfied that that is I
would have said almost a non-material
amendment but as it's part of a package
in the suite of section 73 applications
we have brought it before you we are
recommending approval thank you Jeff
thank you for that are there any
questions councillor Carter this is just
an apology for pee spasms that might
appear to be of a bit of a breeze behind
the head is anything the promise if I
put my hat on to stop you please do
cancel please do thank you so hard would
you like to move somewhere else to sit
somewhere else it might be less drafty
no no no make yourself comfortable and
if you need to go out put your hand up
and we'll get some help for you thank
you yes let's take a little break now to
get some comfort for one of our
counselors they're just 10 minute break
for a quick coffee please
you
refresh thank you very much indeed so we
can resume and we got to the point I
think were there any questions for the
officer I think that was it wasn't it
yeah any questions then no right in that
case we have mr. David Park again if
you'd like to come forward if you want
three minutes
you're very welcome please come and
you've said all that you need to say can
I just ask members are there any
questions relating to this item for the
applicant at all no right okay then
thank you very much and then we have
council burn again thank you very much
well thank you madam chairman yes these
these variations to the original seemed
even more minor than the than the
previous ones were and to that extent I
have no rule of objections to them the
retrospective applications we've heard
how strongly their dislike their dislike
particularly by our residents and as I
am Warp member and I remember a resident
myself of of Yaxley Village you can
imagine just how resentful my fellow
residents are of all these respective
applications failing us to accommodate
such a large development on the doorstep
without any observable recompense
directly to the village that's fine
none was expected but some of the
resident
do it's even even worse when the
observation is made that you know the
larger the applicant the more the more
they try to abuse the system if you like
to call it that I'm not suggesting that
there's been any abuse in this
particular case but that is the
perception one thing I will say about
this application I noticed it in some of
the drawings that even drawings
submitted with the application a differ
one against it one against the other the
position of the staircase or external
access ladders or whatever you like to
call them on on one drawing that's
submitted with this is different to that
on another and there are other
differences too I mean it sort of
highlights the fact that been so many
changes to this application that the
applicant that Africans themselves have
been unable to keep pace with them to
the point where they submit consistent
drawings with the same application now
this probably wouldn't have happened had
there been contact continuous contact
with the planners as in when these days
changes were were were being introduced
for very good reason and I accept the
good reasons but that that contact as
we've already heard has not taken place
and I think it is an object lesson for
all concerned I mean I have to say that
I noticed that some of the variations in
the in the building occurred at least
six months before our case officer was
aware of them in which case you know
that there is something
remiss in in all of that however as I
say in planning terms I cannot see that
the changes in respect of this
particular aeration and denitrification
or whatever it is tank and the
associated building warrant objection to
the point of of a refusal but that's not
my decision it's yours
thank you for that counselor I just have
a question however was there any
engagement right at the beginning with
the local residents of your village and
parish was there yes indeed the water
sir that's all right if you did have we
did have visitation is from visitation
is it a flying the chicken physical
music okay thank you for your help on
that well thank you anyone else have any
questions for the world member no I
think that's all very helpful in which
case we move on to due date and wants to
go for that one Carrie Mathison yeah I
think I think this one is extremely
straightforward and that I shall propose
approval as recommended without delay
Thank You councillor and councillor
Carter I know I'm second out as well
thank you for that so proposing a
seconder does anyone wish to speak at
all or can we go straight to the vote in
that case may we go to the vote please
all those in favor and we are unanimous
thank you very much indeed and thank you
very much everybody
so we now move on to the final item of
the day
page 87 and massa will present this case
for us please sorry counselor are you
are you're our ward member silly me
master if you'd like to present the case
thank you very much hello everyone this
is submission of reserved matters
following an approval of bath line at
appeal babe room itself II refused the
outline initially in 2013 the applicant
appealed against the decision there was
a hearing public hearing and it took a
long time and finally in 2016 it was
allowed at appeal so these reserved
matters application is following to that
this is the site as you can see it's to
the edge of neither market northwest of
neither market it's away from the
historic core and a conservation area
and you can see also stop the gold disc
all the snacks that are adjacent to the
side and as you will note there are
different densities but they are
predominantly of high densities to the
south east of the site is anderson
closed and the north northeast of the
site is Meadowview i will explain
further and following a slice ill-gotten
are sorry as you can see this is a
constraint map there's great to
Hillhouse to north east of the site but
it's reasonably away from the sides so
heritage team identified negligible
impact upon the setting and character of
the great - listed building there are
also a number of TPS as you can see
those green dots and there are a number
of group TPS again further away from the
site which will further reduce any
adverse impact upon dose as a result of
the proposal and as you can see the blue
ribbons show the floodplains again
comfortably away from the development
this is the aerial photography of the
site
it shows the context of the site within
the wider setting also shows some
landscape characteristics of the site
and neighboring developments sanding the
sides this is again similar image aerial
photography it shows that the site is
neither isolated or disconnected from
the settlement in needham market this is
the redline boundary so this is the
proposed layout after development the
layout compromises 37 dwellings accessed
by a single point of here house lane the
density is 24 per hectare this was
determined at appeal is one of the
conditions of the Inspectorate mix of
dakar semi-detached and as motorists if
dwellings the latter limited to the
fordable housing element of the scheme
housing miss compromises of to one bed
ten to bed nineteen three beds and six
quart bed Wellings vehicle accommodation
to compromises integral and detached
garages to fordable housing houses
provided unenclosed onsite college
spaces all of the dwellings are two
stories apart from two single-story
dwellings again the key has been
provided so the two bungalows are
situated to the edge of the development
to the southwest of the site pink I
believe 13 affordable housing which
compromises 35 percent of the whole of
the development are clustered to the
north eastern corner of the site and I
point out to you that orientation is not
correct but but in the next slide I will
I will demonstrate how do sit
so the eastern here house then hydras
retained
aside from where punctuated by the
proposed main access road and five
double vehicle crossings existing mature
trees and at the sides perimeter are
retained an extensive cops areas are
proposed to northern and eastern site
boundaries a proposed foot path from
from and I would call them internal
roads within the development are
proposed to Anderson closed and also to
Meadow View but all again demonstrating
the further slides so this is the real
position of the site in connection with
its neighbors with a neighbor and called
the sac
as you can see okay so as you can see
it's kind of a typical layout of a
residential development of this side as
you can see there are two axes and two
footpaths have been proposed one here to
Meadow View which is this development as
you can see Meadow View compromises of
contemporary modern dwellings and
they're quite large detached dwellings
in their settings and here in Anderson
close the density is much higher and
locus that the footpath comes here and
goes to Anderson close these two
footpaths
they offer better connected connectivity
to the to the wider setting there's a
public footpath here and there is also a
public footpath along the north east of
the boundary along here as I'm pointing
out here
Anderson close slopes steeply from the
bottom when you start from here it's
kinda
steep but as you arrived here the the
slope is kind of more gentle so again I
will demonstrate to you in the further
photographs that it's almost flat so
it's not as intense as the slope within
anderson close in this in this part so
the applicant has provided us with
illustrations of a typical elevation as
you can see but in the furthest like I
will connect them to how do would appear
if you were standing in the yeah in the
layout basically what you would see so
as you can see a a shows the view from
that access to the top as you can see
that this the slope is quite gentle it's
nothing like Anderson closes which is
much much steeper and Beebe shows shows
the elevation and had it would appear
and see see at the bottom is also
illustration of again typical elevation
of the proposed dwellings I'll give you
a minute observe
and planting and planting and
landscaping has not been shown here this
is just purely to show the slope and
also just just a general appearance of
the proposed dwellings and here is the
view from how he's slain Hill hassling
sorry and this is a soft landscaping
that has been proposed as you can see if
I point out to you this part forms the
shared boundary to Anderson close and as
you can see extensive planting has been
proposed which offers the screening and
also just softens the built form and to
this side as well extended landscaping
has been proposed and Jacqueline has
also offered to woodland plantation
areas as I'm pointing out to you this is
strip here and also this one again this
was something that was addressed by the
inspector YZ and I was dealt with at
that line stage which helps the
development to sit well in its setting
and also again reduces any adverse
impact upon a special on scape area
this is the view to the basically access
to the side entrance to the side this
house is part of the Meadow View
[Music]
development this photo was taken when
the application was was refused as you
can see there's no planting this is the
top of Anderson close and there are no
planting there's no hedgerows or
anything like that that would kind of
provide a screening and privacy for for
the occupiers in Anderson close however
I went on site last week and I've taken
number of photos and I'm going to share
that with you in just shortly just one
minute please
thank you okay so this is this is a site
and as you can see did the boundary we
can see the Mutual trees and hedgerows
is where the public access public
footpath is this is now if you remember
the previous image I showed you there
were no hedgerows no plantations nothing
but at the moment there's a mature
established hedgerows and trees being
planted to the show boundaries with
anderson closed again this is another
image in this photo i wanted to
demonstrate the depth of the gardens in
anderson close these are relatively long
gardens with approximately 25 meters
distance from the closest dwelling there
has been proposed
this is the shared boundary with
anderson closed and a new development
and where the new footway has been
proposed connecting anderson closed with
the new development in this photo I was
hoping to demonstrate a high density of
Anderson close and how close the
properties are placed in relation to the
new development which is a 24 per
hectare much lower density than Anderson
closed in this photo I just want to show
the different level the gradient of the
land but you can see the hedgerows at
the top is where Hill house Lanie's
again he just shows the land is
relatively flat in comparison to
Anderson close and here's me standing on
top of your house Lane taking the photos
from there again as you can see I would
like to point out it's relatively it's a
very gentle slope in that part
and these are some of the properties in
Meadow View as I said they feature some
contemporary modern design and at a much
lower density than Anderson clothes
similar to what's been proposed
just not the properties and also the
garages similar to what's been proposed
this shows the width of Hill House Lane
where the development has been proposed
to the northwest of the side there's a
public footpath there and also I'm not
sure if it's evidence but to the left of
the picture is a sign shows public
footpath the site is well connected the
layout sits well and it's mainly
adhering to an indicative plan that was
approved a path line and for that reason
for those reasons we have recommended
approval thank you very much thank you
very much and can you just show us on an
overhead plan or something the
connectivity between this proposed site
and a play area I believe there are some
play areas that the is that Crowley Park
that you're referring to
yeah okay just just so that we can see
how far it is away on a site for play
equipment because obviously it is not
okay there it is yes thank you
yes thank you
[Music]
of course
okay Crowley Park is here right so and
there's a public footpath here there's a
public footpath here and again I said
two new foot ways have been proposed
again improving the connectivity of the
site to the wider wider settlement and
here is Crowley Park I guess the maid is
less than half a mile away bidding I
can't be sure
don't quote me on that no thank you for
that that was just my question so that
members could see where some play area
was for the community proposed community
right any questions councillor hang for
it but yeah thank you and just one
question you said there's two access
points can you confirm the answer
closest be for vehicle access which is
public footpath access there is one
access to the development one point axis
of development but to public foot ways
have been proposed as part of the
development any further questions
councillor matheson men council war boys
thank you the presumably presumably suck
on the outline includes bringing that
some of the female slain farm farm track
essentially up to up to a highway
standards does it chairman yes the just
so we're all clear the appeal decision
that relates to this is in your bundle
and the conditions that were imposed
were effectively on page 127 through to
bear with me 131 they do include parking
and maneuvering access arrangements but
you'll see on pay
136 I may take it down to 36 you'll see
that Kate counsel who commented that
they're into the details of satisfactory
they have made a couple can suggestions
regarding additions or so they do
express an interest in details of the
pros access to the highway in the
right-of-way so there's a little further
detail that they want to see but that is
conditional material and broadly
speaking their perspective on the
highways information that is it's
acceptable so I don't know that
necessarily involves making up Hill
House Lane any further than what you see
albeit you know there is some element of
a conditional detail to sort out here
thank you yes counselor Matheson yeah
I'm not sure I'm just through that I
mean at the moment it's it's a
singletrack
concrete road and we're talking about
the single access to 37 dwellings Jamie
yeah the advice you have for the highway
authority and I'll put it no stronger
than that is what you've got on page 136
and 137 and they say the details are
satisfactory so I think the question of
the appropriateness of hilt outlet Hill
House Lane and others who may know more
can probably comment on this was
reversed as part of the appeal
discussion you've obviously got quite a
lengthy appeal decision it's rehearsal
of a number of issues in the papers and
I won't bore members here today with
that but suffice to say for the purposes
of this morning's consideration of a
reserved matters application what you
have on page 137 136 says the details
proposed in this layout are satisfactory
and subject to the condition I can only
say that you know what you have there
they describe proposals for the
adoptions of Road I'm assuming that the
measurement engineer involved in this is
an experienced officer and knows what
he's dealing with
as Lawal boys
thank you sighs me it's it's another
question about the hill house lane
really the officers showed us a
photograph of an unbroken hedgerow along
the side and yes I believe it's the one
on the left-hand side is another slide
that would at the present time that
edger is completely unbroken and it's
been brought up in the conclusion and
also by the appeals officer and I was
just referring back to the proposed
development site of the access which
just shows a single axis but looking at
the layout I believe the accesses along
that edge was broken up by several m4 I
think of maybe more six six double width
access points to get presumably two
garages page one five nine
I think you're referring to slide eight
is it that we want is that what you're
referring to
principal Street elevation slide eight
that's going yeah yes I think that's
so you have the central access point and
then you have the drive driveways on
either side of it I think there's five
double with driveways which breaks up
the hedgerow completely and that's been
referred to by the appeals officer the
appeal decision that there's an
alternative site appraisal screen which
showed how the layout of the proposed
development could be amended to reduce
the number of openings into Millhouse
Lane is it is that is the reduction of
the openings part of our conditions or
not yes it can be it can we can use a
suitable condition to to reduce it
however we felt at the moment it's
suitable given the double garages and
access to dues needed and the applicant
is provided is has retained the
hedgerows as as much as possible and
this is what has been referred to the
appeal decision as where for it to be
retained as much as possible and I think
we are at a stage well it has me
retained as much as possible
shall we come to that one in the debate
counselor voice and we can always come
back to the officers for further
explanations on that one and we can
explore it during debate what do you
think yeah okay thank thank you
yeah
so are there any further questions at
the moment
just one moment while they just have a
confirmation
come back to this point we need to look
at 1 5 9 it does show us some
landscaping with regard to your issue so
if we can have Martin Goodwin the
applicant or agent if you'd like to come
forward please and if you just stick to
the three minutes and then you will have
some questions which might lose the date
on the issue that we're looking at at
the moment but your three minutes please
and press the button Thank You Martin
Goodwin collates architects I represent
the applicant as agent the African
tanned and the cells are pleased to have
been through a constructive dialogue
with your offices and to adjust and
amend original proposals submitted in
order to respond to some neighbor and
consultant comments with the reserved
matters application that follows was
consistent with the master plan true for
there was a wider development area if it
is approved if you deemed to approve
this reserved matters I can assure you
that the the local developer won't be
land banking this it's due for
commencement in the spring of next year
for delivery in autumn 2021 were pleased
that the officers positive report and
the applicant is happy to accept
suggestions of changing planting species
and any issues relating to reduction in
width of openings to garages and we we
would only ask that slab levels of
houses could be dealt with as a
condition
on development of some technical design
sort of following on from planning
approval Thank You chairman thank you
for that um do members have questions
yes counselor Madison yeah the I have to
say I was very disappointed with this
that the actual layout of the houses and
I wondered whether you'd considered
other approaches to it there's there's
two reasons for that and you know the
question really is have you thought
about this the first one is that if if
the rut the five houses on Hill House
Lane were facing into the site then they
would not cut through the hedge so very
many times and the second even more
fundamental point really is did you
consider the the potential for solar
game but because the site although the
site does not slope tremendously it does
slow southeast I went to look and you
know did you did you consider that a
possibility and I refer to any PPF 148
150 on that well thank you counselor the
site has been sort of laid out in a
coherent and logical way sort of bearing
in mind the constraints of sort of
orientation and constraints and
boundaries the decision early on was to
make a forward facing sort of road
facing development and that was
sort of accepted as a design driver from
an early at an early stage and and and
in discussion with officers
we had maintained the hetero to the
front on the basis that is adjacent the
rural landscape and there has been a lot
of planting proposed within the site and
and to the other boundaries also a
twenty meter wide strip of woodland to
the southern boundary which will I think
we're sort of debating this here we just
want to know the answer to the question
which showed the cats are asked and I
think you know it needs to be a little
bit more succinct to sort of give us a
bit of confidence in in what's happening
here
would you agree counselor yet that's
what I was thinking yeah thank you
um just one moment please
any more questions for the applicant no
okay thank you very much if you'd like
to return to your seat
I think Phillip wants to do a little bit
of an update for us which might help us
in our quest Thank You chairman just a
little bit of housekeeping
um so recommendation on page 95 is -
groans Planning Commission and obviously
members here will have realized that sir
deliberate error on the part officers we
know that we've already granted we
already have a Planning Commission in
place so actually the request here is to
authorize the approval of the reserved
matters so relevant grant Planning
Commission if we can just correct that
recommendation to approve the reserved
matters you'll see also that are on page
96 we recommended that withdraw PD
rights following further discussion by
officers we're not proposing the
Beedrill of 22n rights the inspector had
quite a white suite of conditions and
discussion as part of his appeal so
we're not proposing to add anything
that's more owners to that it's quite a
generous layout and our a view is that
it's reasonable to allow occupiers to do
the reasonable things that people do in
their own homes and lastly
then we've also suggested a construction
plan as a condition that's on page 96
but really speaking that duplicates with
condition 20 on the outline permission
so strictly speaking there is already
provision made for by the appeal
inspector for resolution of construction
management issues now as far as
landscaping goes clearly you have a
submission before you today and you may
or may not find that acceptable that's
for members that committee the question
of the hydro along hill house lane was
knowledged I think is an issue as part
of the consideration by the appeal
inspector and
I can see that referenced within the
appeal decision in various places
clearly if you're content or not
contending thoughts before you that's a
choice for this morning I mean from our
point of view as officers we're content
and putting this forward to you that's
that's for your judgement as regards
acceptability but what it would say is
this scheme largely draws upon I think
the outline scheme in in working up the
details it includes what's the right
phrase it includes the right density the
inspector specifically required a
density at 24th of hectare and not less
and not more and therefore you have 37
drawings which I think largely do take
the thrust of the original application
forward into reserve matters I think
really poor the rest is for debate by
members thank general thank you that
sort of tardies that up so we are now
open to debate don't know or not we're
not yeah how could I forget the council
in Norris
please can we hear from you thank you I
do have some concerns regarding this
application I fully support the child
Anita market Town Council's comments on
page 88 particularly in respect of the
location being within a special
landscape area local plan policies cl2
applies which states that where
development does occur it should be
sensitivity designed with high standards
of layered materials and landscaping
also the capacity of existing drainage
and sewage infrastructure Anglian waters
comments on page 89 conclude by
recommending that the local planning
authority should seek the advice of the
lead local flood of authority or the
internal drainage board I cannot look at
any evidence in the papers this has been
carried out
I'm surprised that it appears to have
been dismissed on page 94 under
paragraph 8 land contamination flood
risk drainage and waste as new issues of
relevance have arisen and the final
mayor mentioned by the Town Council
being the clustering of the affordable
housing element within the proposed
layout on page 159 there have been a
number of objections submitted by
residents relating to the proximity of
plot 17 to 22 in the proposed layout on
page 159 to the existing residential
properties in Anderson closed on the
grounds of overlooking loss of privacy
loss of light and potential devaluation
of their properties the land continues
to rise from Anderson close across the
area of the Peru's development proposed
development to the extent that the
proposed dwellings on plots 17 to 22
will be dominant and above the level of
the adjoining existing properties in
Anderson closest contravenes policy 816
protecting existing residential amenity
as members will have seen from the
slides the application site is on a
continual slope
I think the clues in the name Hill House
Leyna land in this area is higher than
the sir
land and sloped down towards Henderson
closed I would suggest actually it would
be advantageous for committee members to
be able to appreciate the topography of
the land for themselves I would
recommend that a site visit is carried
out thank you thank you for that
counselor I think mr. Isabel was
listening carefully to you and has one
of two points to make I just would
mention that I'd actually notice about
the special landscape area but correct
me if I'm wrong Phillip is that no
longer in our local plan are those local
those special landscape areas being
taken out I heard a voice from the floor
it is at the moment so it's in the local
plan so it so it's in the local plan but
as we move to all the junk locally it is
it is going it is it is it attracts less
white and certainly in advise you you
see within national no guidance
local designations like special
landscape area get lesser weight I mean
I think in fairness in this instance we
have an outline decision where a lot of
that got weighed so I wasn't looking to
rehearse a special landscape area
argument given that it had probably been
covered quite fully by the inspector my
carry-on journey yes please so as
regards page 94 and the comment rather
brief to say the least comment on flood
risk well clearly the inspector dealt
with flooding himself and I think this
was the subject of some debate so if I
draw members attention to the conditions
on page 120 1820 on occasions 14 15 16
effectively you do have provisions
relating to surface water management and
drainage and I recall there was quite a
logic an interest in that issue so to
that extent when the details come
forward for that we will consult the
lead flood authority on those my advice
in privacy of these four walls is that
perhaps
Anglian Water are not as familiar with
our outline applications as planning on
I'll leave it there thank you for that
so further questions for the ward member
if any of you gentlemen would like to
have anything no thank you very much
indeed counselor so we are now open to
debate so I think I saw a hand
I think counselor Carter was sort of
first off earlier on he had a first hand
up or to start with I'm gonna explain
why I've been possibly a bit naughty and
not declared an interest in this because
I was a member of V friends need to
market countryside six years ago but
fist was before this developments was a
part that I'd after second a council
Norris's comments regarding force type
and the topography we are today looking
at it's the swallow if this has already
been granted on me it is hasn't it so I
am trying to look at it it says a with
council hat on today of just this
development yeah it does concern me
regarding what clock needs to be put
there about what residents may end up
living there in regards to the access
going from this site see the rest of the
town to get some facilities I'm not
certain at this point whether or not the
properties that we have listed today are
going to be the best suited to the area
so problem is I don't have a better
suggestion because it's not really the
best area to have houses all stop but
yeah we have to get over that one is
that it's it's gone through just
certainly wouldn't be suitable for
anyone in a wheelchair here wants to get
into a set of town I mean for your
points on that and canceller Matheson
was next today thank you I um before I
plunge into debate I wanted to ask mr.
E's bill this casually contra said the
this one goes back some years does in
David with this now that do we are we
with reference to the current MPP F now
or do we have to look back to when it
was appeal so so I would say to you as a
reserved matters application it's not
strictly speaking a planning application
but your consideration should be to have
regard to the end PPF and the priming
practice guidance as it exists today the
local plan is obviously a document of
some elderly vintage the core strategy
is relevant and you've got away all
those things together but in terms of
the NPP f yes I would say the the
current version of that document is the
thing that I would be advising you to
pay attention to
that's for Humphreys thank you okay
thank you
current from different slightly
different angle it's with inside the
neighborhood plan I know it's not been
agreed yet but it is in there if you
were thinking about a logical place to
build a development with an existing
town and you look down on need to market
this would be a logical place to put it
we've been building houses and villages
on on Hills since we started building
because it's the logical place to build
so that argument the hill stuff so you
throw it out of the window really it's
just the way it is when I look at the
spread of buildings on their 24 per
hectare that's fantastic so we've got
low density that's a good thing
we'll look at the types of buildings
within this development coming to
councillor Carter's point actually we've
got an excellent mix
for all abilities all ages we've got two
bedroom three bedroom and bungalows and
it's the bungalow bit which is fantastic
and we would talk about accessibility
you've actually got really good
footpaths and accessed the rest of the
town through the understand closed area
which is the bottom of the estate so I
think as far as accessibility goes it
ticks all the boxes not I don't think
there's an argument against that I can't
see any reason for turning this down
player application has already been
accepted so all the arguments about
edges and sustainability and all that
pretty much have been argued before I'm
sure they're hedges along deed the new
access road
I do get your point counsel Madison I'm
a fan of hedges I think they should be
maintained and they try to maintain that
as best they can because the alternative
is I'm not a planner I'm not a house
builder or a developer but a fairly
illogical and I think if you turn that
around I'll need two extra roads we
should reduce the amount of garden space
and therefore affect the lifestyle that
people living on the estate so you can't
have your cake and eat it and I think
actually this is a fairly reasonable
given the size and the low density of
the area a reasonable plan and the loss
of those small portions of the hedgerow
due to the requirement for parking and
there is a requirement I think that
would sort of cancel it out and I know
you're of a different opinion and that's
absolutely fine it's just my point and
so all in all I minded to move for
approval I'm not going to do that yet
until other people have spoken but I
just can't see any reason that you could
refuse it okay Cass the council of war
boys thank you well I agree with a great
deal of what has just been said
regarding the approval of Planet it is
quite an acceptable plan and an
acceptable site and I think there have
been great efforts made with regard to
the landscaping in particular sort of 20
20 meters of planting however I think I
would like to just under reason
as we're now into sort of reserved
matters I think I would like to see the
the reduction of the driveways onto the
onto the hill house lane
it was simply sort of minimize the
disruption to the hedgerow I don't think
it would at all really sort of
inconvenience of people whose garages
were there if anything it will give them
more privacy because more of the
hedgerow would be retained I think it's
very important this takes to sort of
minimize the sort of impact on the
existing environment there it is a
special landscaper and then the less
impact we can have the better from my
point of view this has been mentioned by
the appeals officer and and I could see
it has been a recommended change to this
to the access onto Hill House Lane so I
think I'll reserve matters we could we
could perhaps pass it like that
councillor wall boys are you suggesting
that on the double garages there's a
hedge put in front of one garage and
you're hoping that the sufficient
turning space to get in from the wrong
entrance you're suggesting I don't know
yes exactly retaining the hedgerow and
just having a single access point which
is what the on page one one well the
Appeal decision reduced the number of
openings on to Hill House Lane which
would lead to the retention of more
substantial section of Asia along much
of the frontage on that point if that
was something that you were interested
in we'd have to defer and go away to let
the offices debate that and discuss it
with the applicant but let's move carry
on with the debate but that's just
something and that we would need to do
we can't just do it here
now okay okay can you turn your
microphone off please
sorry um and who hasn't had a speech yet
I think you've had a go counselor
matheson anyone else wishing to speak at
all
well the questions were a long time
since counselor and but we'll carry on
no one else wishing to speak no all
right then well you've had and did you
oh I beg your pardon
well well counselor matheson a bit
upsetting did I think counselor matheson
about thank you thank you yes I I think
on the the weather weather offices need
to go away or not to look at this this
question of reducing the double width to
single width I thought at 7.4 that the
officer was suggesting that we could we
could dive straight in and make that the
condition but anyway I'd be interested
to hear what what the officers say about
that however as I hinted in my question
to the architect you know this this
could be done better and and the the the
is the slope as you've seen it might
it's not a steep slope but the NPP
effort does ask us to it asks the
applicants to take account of the land
it does slope southeast that advantage
is not being used in this instance and
and as as councillor Norris said there
should be sensitivity regarding the
special landscape area and so overall
I'm not prepared to support this layout
on this site I'll be obviously that it
has outlined permission from the
inspector Thank You counselor counselor
Humphreys mum sure thank you I'm just
looking at design of it and the slope
and I think I mean and this is arguable
and we've both got different opinions on
this that actually they have thought
about the slope that's while the
bungalows at the top of the hill and the
big house at the bottom and it doesn't
slope as much dancing clothes it's also
in keeping with
other properties are already on there
and in terms of loss of immunity the
since January myself in the northern
hemisphere I don't see there's any loss
of light not that that really matters to
be honest you to understand close and
the only time they do lose it I believe
is probably when the sun's rising in the
morning other than that they've got it
for most of the day and you can see that
purely God just looking at the map and
imagine yourself they've put a North
point you're on to help us so I think a
lot of the argument be explored and the
design I don't know a lot of design I
don't see how you can design it any
better than what they've done low
density real good consideration about
the slope in my opinion and
accessibility i'm maanna to move for
approval and that's what i'll do said
lunch proposed approval the reserve
matters and conditions sir thank you
very much anyone else wishing to speak
who hasn't spoken already cancer gold
just two second cancer Humphries
proposal thank you for that and then
counselor Carter I now spoken already
[Music]
however we've heard a fair few comments
on neck security on recommendations
through people who haven't experienced
what it is like if the the area from a
perspective of somebody who has got a
disability if this was to be referred
for a site visit and maybe Lucy aides
were provided but so it she could see
the topography of a land from a
perspective of a wheelchair user and
this or see whether or not the
suitability is for the house Amin plot
that where regardless of where the house
is planted on a flat level of land
whether is there they still have to get
to that area they still have to go
through vehicle types and they still
have to do some quite uneven landing
which is there it doesn't say in a plan
whoever got that they would be leveling
both allowed to make it more accessible
it doesn't say regarding video
in height over the ground which if you
visit at the site there are differences
in heights from level so either this
goes to for referral regarding the fee
they've got the be the driveway issues
which I wouldn't be opposed to or if we
had a second that if we had a favorite
site visit where people could actually
see for themselves and rather than going
on a later perspective when you're with
you can't really say with anything
regarding V accessibility unless you
actually genuinely know and that is
something but you do have to learn from
experience thank you for that cancer and
point it's very well made and very well
taken the only problem I have with that
sort of debate is I was in Cornwall last
weekend and they have hills there
regularly and you know there must be
difficulties and I I do appreciate what
you're saying it's very helpful but from
a personal point of view and I feel that
we can hope that the pavements and
suchlike are suitable for people
searching wheelchairs and buggies so I'm
a little bit worried about using that as
a refusal point I think who wants to say
something German I mean I think it's an
important point and I recollect it was
something that councillor Carter himself
was you know I'd an active part in the
consideration of this the this
application when it was before the
inspector and indeed I think somewhere
during the appeal mass we've been fifty
paragraph fifty paragraph 15 of Appeal
on page hundred and fourteen the
inspector said it was apparent from my
site visit the footwear Long Hill House
Lane Israel to be narrow being a meter
in width that it's no point the occupant
of the wheelchair was however able to
navigate a light
despite its width in graded although
this route may not be ideal for
wheelchair users there is another
pedestrian route available from the
appeal site along property footpath fp3
week which
which access to both accounts central
needham market and the stone market road
can be gained and the inspector then
said I'm satisfied therefore the
professor will be accessible to all
future residents yeah accepting that
there are differing opinions around this
and that ultimately you know your best
guided by what you see on sight in some
ways we have an outline decision on an
inspectors judgement of that matter and
I'm not sure quite where I would advise
committee to take it as a result that's
helpful while I was speaking almost will
continue to speak I think the layouts
quite good I think there are a mix of
properties there it's been through
extensive debates appeals and so on and
I will be supporting this application so
unless anybody else wishes to speak on
the motion I don't feel that the site
visit is necessary and I'm quite happy
to go to the back councillor may I have
senior counsel of Norris but let the
debate run if you would please counsel
in there I do feel the point about the
hedges were made I like to see that
retained but I don't think going to
single driveways will work without
moving the properties back that would
reduce available garden space putting
extra internal roads will have drainage
impacts so I think it makes the best of
what is a difficult situation retain
what we can of the hedge but maximise
the layout so the residents benefit
[Music]
right well we are in debate so cancel
Norris I'm afraid you can't join in on
that so on this point now then I have a
proposer in a second or so all those in
favor please vote and those against
for Sharon scarfing food was it full no
it's only three you've miscounted it's
three to four
whistles the meeting to check with got
everything sorted site inspections done
Jeff thank you very much
and so that is that thank you very much
indeed
[Applause]